all right here to talk about that and
more as Kevin Sorelli chief Washington
correspondent for Bloomberg Television
Kevin good morning we'll go back to the
debate in a minute but let's start with
what we heard overnight from President
Trump we're hearing that they're gonna
resume trade talks between China and at
least for now no more new tariffs will
be imposed what can we make of all of
this top line view the president
suggesting that there has been a u-turn
of sorts and an easing of the rhetorical
back-and-forth between President Xi
Jingping and President Trump but if you
dive a little bit deeper into the weeds
the president saying that China has said
that they're going to make more
agricultural purchases good news for
farmers good news for some of those
battleground states that the president's
gonna need some win back if he wants to
win reelection but he also said that the
US has agreed to ease some of the
restrictions against Chinese
telecommunications firm Huawei that
might face some pushback this weekend
from not just Democrats and
congressional leadership but also some
key Republicans like Senator Lindsey
Graham and Marco Rubio another key
moment in the g20 summit came with the
moment between Putin President Putin and
President Trump when President Trump
told him don't meddle in our elections
but I mean what kind of pushback is he
gonna get well he's already getting that
pushback Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer the Democrat from New York
putting out a statement saying that this
is evidence for why he believes the
president isn't taking seriously enough
the threat of cyber security issues
pertaining to democratic elections that
said the the president and his
supporters are saying well look he did
it on camera he just pointed directly to
Vladimir Putin and said that but a lot
of body language and facing that
criticism and we've seen that just
within the last day all right let's talk
about that that debate no and the
dispute now between Kamala Harris and
Joe Biden Joe Biden clearly was in
damage control yesterday how is that
working out for him right now he's
trying to get back on offense he is
trying to tell his record on his terms
but I can tell you you could have heard
a pin drop
and that's spin room Duran in Miami
during the debate during that particular
exchange as every reporter was was
carefully watching his this.d
a beginning of an ascent for Senator
Kamala Harris and it was something they
clearly had ready right with the t-shirt
and everything else but it was still
delivered well absolutely and then from
her vantage point she's really trying to
capitalize on this her campaign saying
that they've already smashed fundraising
records but in addition to that there
were some other breakdown candidates I
think that when you look at senator
Elizabeth Warren from night one when you
look at someone like senator Bernie
Sanders I caught up with him in the spin
room after he says that he's going to do
everything he can to break up big banks
but I got to be candid here that divided
within the Democratic Party on economic
vision it was on full display and when I
interviewed chairwoman Ronna Romney
McDaniel of the RNC in Miami she called
that type of economic vision
quote-unquote frightening so the battle
lines are already being drawn they're
drawn and quartered yes so does the
heavens really thank you so much to be
here